good morning believe nation today's
message is live your life over to you
Ben Affleck if you could give advice to
your 25 year old self what would you say
you know I'd be inclined to say you know
so watch out for this guy and don't
spend money on this and buy real estate
right up until 2007 and then dump it all
that kind of thing but the truth is
about youth and experience and success
and failure is that you just have to go
live it and experience it and if you
don't it doesn't make you a mature adult
I think that you're defined by how you
rise more than how you fall one of the
most important lessons that I ever
learned as a human being from Jeff Bezos
and I've told this story a couple times
in the channel but the idea is to live
life with no regrets he was the guy who
is having massive success I just firm
where he was the youngest vice president
ever at his company and he left it he
threw it all away to start a business
called Amazon where people thought he
was crazy who would ever buy books
online why are you throwing away the
successful career to do this thing and
his answer was he want to live with
regret he could live with it not working
but he did not want to live with her
Brett and so he called it in a very
technical term the regret minimization
framework where basically whenever
you're afraid to make a decision fast
forward your life to h7t you're looking
back or maybe by the time we get there
9150 look back on your life say my going
to regret saying yes or saying no to
this and if you're going to regret it
then take the opposite action do it and
so this really came into play into my
life when I was in Paris and I was a
tourist and this girl came up in asking
for directions and I wanted to ask her
out and I was too afraid to do it and I
just pointed her in the direction she
wanted to go and I didn't ask her out
and then I took a picture as she was
walking across the the bridge to the
other side of the street and and I
didn't actually get her in the picture I
couldn't tell because it wasn't digital
at the time
and I put that picture I printed it off
big and I put it on my wall at home put
it in my bedroom
as a reminder not to live with regret as
a reminder the next time that I get in
that situation I want to do something
but I'm too afraid to do it because the
alternative is not knowing and you can
deal with a little bit of short-term
pain right maybe you get rejected maybe
doesn't work out maybe she laughs at you
whatever it is you do a little bit
short-term pain versus a lifetime of not
knowing and so I had that picture on my
wall and people thought it was a
beautiful French picture like yes
I didn't tell anybody the story behind
it and then an opportunity came later on
that year where I had a chance to go
work at the dream company that I thought
I wanted to work at versus being
involved in this startup biotech company
that wasn't making a lot of money making
a 300 bucks a month and that was part of
what helped me decide to stick with the
company and not go get the job where
would be making a 200k a year lots of
opportunities the thing that all my
friends wanted and the companies fly me
to New York and put me up in fancy
hotels and wining and dining and all of
that stuff
saying no to do this small company that
had a little chance of success hadn't
proven itself at all I wasn't making any
kind of real money from it why would I
do that because I could live with the
company failing but I couldn't live with
not knowing and so I try to live my life
ever since that point of reducing as
many regrets as possible and every time
I ask myself am I going to regret this
as soon as I get an honest answer that I
know what I have to do so that's my
story and the question today today is
what advice would you give your 25 year
old self just like Ben Affleck did
leaving the comments below
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Liliana
Liliana thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read thank you
guys again for watching I hope you have
an amazing day I believe in you and hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events better
more expresso give me go
proponent is one life and we should make
the best of it and that's what I try to
and best to do the best is not to enjoy
each day as as it's the last they are
celebrating drinking whatever because
tomorrow it could be at the end
no no it's m2 to make it a better place
I think it's only possible in your
surrounding you come in the room try
that the people don't feel worse when
you come in so that's what I try to
thats how i understand life i think a
lot of times you think that the great
writers are the people they just write
hit after hit after hit and they do but
it's also because they get through all
the terrible songs first and I mean I
think that's kind of every single artist
story and and I mean I love to talk when
people ask what's your best advice for
you know upcoming musician or anybody I
think it's that you have to be able to
rise from the failures is what makes a
successful person because everybody's
going to have mishaps they're going to
fall down and it's you know the people
that continuously pick themselves up
that are the ones that are going to find
their voice make it whatever you want to
call it